Mẹ bà tháng buổi năm 2019, chiếc xe định xe ông bị su bẩy ơn tra gặp nạn và bốc trẻ tại thành đô.
Chúng khúc khiến năm tại sẽ tử vong.
Theo tức gọi điều tra, bà xe trước từ điểm và trạc, chiếc xe trẻ với tụi khoảng 2.8 kí lồ mấy trình dở.
Giảm xuống còn buch trong 6.9 kí lồ mấy trình dở tại từ điểm đâm vào xe phi trước và giảm còn buch trong 8.8 kí lồ mấy trình dở khi tông vào dài phân các.
Nhưng người thăm gia thứ ộ không thể mực sự xe sau hệ thống định bị mất nguồn.
Cử dụi xe không thể mở tụi bình hỏi vì bà trạc hiện hiện thống định á thấp mất nguồn làm vô hiệu hóa chức năng mở cửa bằng tay nắm.
Bà cao cũng lưu gió, xe được trong vị nút mùa cửa định đi ngoài, khi không có tay nắm cơ khi hình tất có thể hòa đậu khi mất định.
Chức hiếng lồ hại vì vấn đề an toàn, bố công việc ở cơ người thông tin trong quốc đã sợ thảo vụ tư trên bắt mục mỗi đứa tây nắm cửa ổ tổ.
Thuy định mối, được phép xe được vào thăm 1 năm nay nguồn trong ai mi sao, các cầu tất cả cửa sê phải được trong vị tay nắm cơ khi có thể hãn đồng ngày cả khi mất định, bà vùng cả trong trường vực biến tập sự của hoặc sê ra hệ tượng mất kìm sốt nhìn.
Các niềm sản xuất có thể hạn đến năm nay nguồn trong ai miệng nguồn trong ai miệng bày đề a dụi quy định này cho các mẫu xe bối và đến năm nay nguồn trong ai miệng xử thiết kể đối với các mẫu xe đã dạm mắt.